(musiikkia)
- Voi voi, kun just heräsin ja radios puhutaan jostakin deikokemuksesta ja implusiivisuudesta ja jostakin rekrytoinnista.
- Ja mistä ihmeistä? Minä en tiedä, kun minulla on vain Suomea opetettu koulussa, ainakin kansakoulussa. Hei hei.
- Soittakaa Kansanradioon, jos teiltä loppuu hermot. Kansanradiossa on hyvää politiikkaa. Nymi Ano.
- Täältä Anna Lan Tampereelta. Haluamme vaan sanoa kiitokset Kansanradiosta. Onneksi ootte olemassa. Eei!
- Hoppila, Satsumas Hoppila. Ottakoon niin vanhan aikasi, jotta teidän ei näe numeroa, mistä täällä soitetaan. Hottilippa ihanpa itse.
- Ai huomenta, pahoittelen. Ei todellakaan mitään hätää tässä karmeissa maailmassa. Hei hei.
- Ei mitään hätää, sillä seuraavan puolen tunnin ajan on luvassa Kansanradiota. Nämä alkupohjelut saattoivat kuulostaa tutuilta, sillä tämän kertainen jakso on täynnä kierrätystavaraa.
Olen koonnut materiaalin noin viimeisen vuoden ajalta. Sekin on hyvin tuttua, kun tässä kohtaa sanon, että tervetuloa taas mukaan ja matkaan. Puoli tuntissa on luvassa ohjelmimme vakioaiheita, esimerkiksi liikennettä, ruokaa ja sotea. Toki muutakin on tarjolla. Tällä kertaa kesäisen kiertyskeskuksen hoitajana toimii Koiviston Lauri. Yksi kansalainen kertoo, että valkoissa talossa on narri.
Toinen taas ehdottaa ottamaan oppia Konsta Pylkkäsestä ja kaivataanpa myös lisää Patakakkosta Yle-areenaan. Nyt me suuntaamme Uimarannalle.
Myös viranomaiset siihen puuttuvat ja ei muuta.
Liikunnan ohjaajille, jotka ovat työttömänä ikään näiltä keltaisia, nämä unolet ja virka. Kiitos, hei.
Hukkuva nousee kaksi kertaa pintaan ja mä olin toista kertaa noussut pintaan ja kääntynyt häneen päin ja hän näki mun silmäni ja tajusi, että ei tuo tyttö kyllä nyt leikikkään. Siinä oli tosi kysymyksissä ja seuraava muistikuva onkin sitten, kun mä makasin äidini polvillaan ja hän pumppasi musta vettä ulos. Kyllä jos silmät näkee, niin kyllä varmaan sitten arvaa, että ei ole leikkimässä eikä pilailemassa. Että tämmöinen pinkki.
Kiitos, hei.
Hei. Helteisiin sopivaa biitsiasiaa eli merihelle asiaa. Samalla lailla niin kuin aikaisemminkin otan kantaa muiden sanomisiin. Siellä joku, jolla on joku tämmöinen hukkumiskokemus tai lähes hukkumiskokemus, niin väitti, että kyllä lapsesta huomaa, että pelleileekö se vai eikö. No mitä jos lähettäisiin siitä oletuksesta, että kukaan ei pelleile tämmöisellä asialla. Että mitä jos vain aikuiset ryntää sinne veteen, jos näyttää siltä, että joku on hukkumassa. Ja sitten otettiin.
Kantaan noihin bikineihin, että ne pitäisi kokonaan kieltää, että uikkarit ovat ne oikeat. Niin en ole ikinä käyttänyt uikkareita enkä käytä ihan siitä syystä, että ne eivät sovi minun kropalleni. Joa, minua ylipäätänsä ihmetyttää se asia, että miksi jotakuta kiinnostaa niin paljon, mitä toisella ihmisellä on päällä. Minua korkeintaan huvittaa, jos minä näen jotain, mikä ei sovi mun silmälle, mitä toisella on päällä. Mutta ei minua sen enempää häiritse, että kukin pukeutuu ihan miten.
Haluaa ja mistä syystä haluaa. Kiitos.
Tuontoajatuksia. Niitä ennen muistutan ohjelmamme postiosoitteesta. Kansanradion voi laittaa kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postiosoitteeseen. Kansanradio pl 790 000 24 Yleisradio.
Vähennetään metsään sen takia, että voidaan olla rauhassa. Niin minkä takia ihmiset tulevat matkalla matkaa ja morjestelee? Ei tänne ole tultu morjestelemaan. Kysyn vaan minkä takia? Kiitos.
Täällä puhuu vanha mummusavosta. Tässä mitteissään on ollut tästä Suomen syntyvyymestä, kun se meinoo mennä ihan nollille. Ja nyt kun se kattohaikara on pestiytynyt tänne Suomeen. Ja ennen sanottiin, että haikarahansa.
Tuonne vaavat niin pistettäisiin nyt sen pienen pojan. Toivotaan, että se on poika. Niin pistetään sen pojan nimeks Toevo. Toivo on hyvä ja toivossa on hyvä, ellei muuta. Kaunis kakesse.
No Jormavaari, vaan Tampereet täästä tervehdys. Tuli vaan tässä mieleen, että kun eläimille julistetaan joulurauha, niin mitä jos julistettaisiin rallirauha edes jonain kesänä? Olis metsän asukkaat varmaan mielisänsä, kun niillä on nyt noin poikasetkin ja pikku linnut ja muut. Kiitos.
Voi ei täällä Pirjo. Kuulin radiosta elän kirjailijan lausuntoa, että kirjoittaa kuin pieni eläin. En ole kyllä eläessäni nähnyt, että mikään eläin voi kirjoittaa kirjaa tai se tekee joku pieni, pieni murainen. Mikä toi oli? Saan en nauraa.
Eteläkala vedeltiin semmoisia huomiota tuossa kun uistinta on vedetty, niin on kalaa vielä aika syvässä, että ei minkään maha, että on auttamatta myöskin liian pienet uistimet ollut meille. Nyt saatiin onneksi vähän parannusta, mutta jännä nähdä tuo Mariakasissa.
Terve käpysi. No jokkaranta tässä kun pitäisi niinku oravaa matkii. Niin matkinko? Ai pitäisi oravaa matkii. Niin sanottiin kansanradiossa, että pitäisi matkia oravaa. Selvä. No matkisitte oravaa. No niin. Eikö se ole näin tuo orava kun ääntelee. No jos näin sanottiin, kiitoksia tästä. Kiitoksia. Tää oli aika yllättävää.
Mutta Orava nääni siinä sitten. Hei hei! No hei hei!
Yn veruotin yhtäältä päivää. Kissampissa ei ole hyvä polttoainetta. Minulla oli auto, joka ysiviitoselle ei kulkenut, mutta kun laitoin ysikasi polttoainetta, niin tuli neljäkyt kilometriin nopeutta lisää. Hei vaan!
Tämän jälkeen onkin paikallaan siirtyä liikenneteemaisten puheluiden pariin.
No se on Nea Orvokki tässä. Terve! Kyllä minä välillä ihmettelen näitä ajaajia tuolla liikenteessä, että jos ei uskalla sillä autolla ajaa, lähellekään ei sitä oikeata rajoitusta, niin pitäisi hommata pussikortti. Eipä mulla muuta.
Kuinka nämä rattijuopput ja huumovirrat ajelevat autoilla ihmisten päälle ja sitten semmoinen laki pitäisi laittaa voimaan niin kuin Tanskassa, joka ajaa ylinopeuksia ja ihmisten päällä ajelevat sumalassa, että autot valtiolle olisi sitten pieni hinkilöauto taikka rekka, joka osallistuu tuommoiseen hommaan, taikka sitten myös varkailta, jotka varastavat ja tekevät ilkeyksiään ajoneuvoilla polkupyörästä viisi vuotta.
Ja jos täällä hiihtäjä soittelee, sähköpotkulauta on moottoriajoneuvo, se ei ole pelkästään avusteinen niin kuin joku sähköllä avustettu polkupyörä sähkömoottorilla, että siinä on iso ero.
Ei siellä olla piruuttamme, kyllä meillä on työt menossa silloin ja voi olla, että se kesämäkkiläiselle ei ole niin kiire, että jos siellä pilkasliikenteellä tiellä väistetään sivuun, niin sieltä hänet takaisin pääsee. Jatkuvasti tulee takaa autoon.
Heippa. Kiitoksia teille. Hyvää päivää. Tässä Joona. No, koskien ihan jokaista paikkakuntaa, mutta ongelma näkyy siellä, missä on eniten julkinen liikenne käytössä. Juna, ratikka tai bussi, kun tulee pysäkille, päästetään ne ihmiset ensiksi sieltä liikennevälineistä pois ennen kuin sinne kukaan änkee sisään. Kyllä se kuski sen odottaa sen hetken, että ihmiset pääsevät ulos ja toiset sitten sisälle. Käytöstavat on huomioitava. Mä en ymmärrä, mikä siinä on.
että ei voi yhtään ajatella toista ja käytöstapoja. Hieman sama ongelmaa näkyy myös pyörätie liikenteessä.
Ei huomioida muita kulkijoita, olisi sitten jalan kulkija. Ajetaan hyvin paljon yksisuuntaista tietä väärään suuntaan.
Tällä varannetaan oma toiminta ja muiden toiminta myös. Asiasta voisi jatkaa monta minuuttia, mutta nyt tuli mitta täyteen tässä hetkessä. Kiitos.
Jos te ette ole jokin muulla kulkuneuolla, niin eväät pitää olla aina kunnossa. Nyt onkin aika nauttia ruokaa ja juomaa.
Vielä kattausta ennen kerron Kansanradion WhatsApp-numeroon. Meille Kansanradion voi laittaa WhatsApp-viestejä sekä tekstikommentteja että äänimuotoisia viestejä, jollaisia muuten on mukana tässä ohjelmassa useampiakin.
Viisi, neljä, kuusi, neljä. Yksinalkanen. Miksi leipurit eivät paista leipiä vaan jätetään puolin raaksi ja keittiöt syöttävät maisia ja riisiä, mihinkä on jätetty ohra?
Mutta siitä mä en tiedä mistä semmoinen sanonta tuleekte. Nyt oli ohra leipä. Kiti.
No nyt sinä kuka vilhelet sitä kaalia Suomessa. Tätä valkokaalia. Tuo markkinoilleni kaalimehu ja ota mut siihen mainostamasta. Saat näkyvyyttä. Ei mun muuta.
Minkä moni prosenttisen tulee kauppoihin ja mitä niinpäin poissa kotiinkuljetuksesta. Kaikki muut. Sitä niin sanottua kiljua saa kotona keittää. Tehää sitä kiljua, sokeria, hiivaa ja mitä siihen saa laittaa ne kotiin. Nää on laillista mutta siitä ei saa tehdä sitä tislata. Tislata virkkaankaan alkoholisi kuin pontikkaani kansankielellä. Niin sitä ei saa tehdä. Se on laissa kielletty. Ja tämä selvityi sitä minkä takia se on kielletty. Se on kielletty sen takia kun tuo kodona valmistelee. Siitä saattaa.
Kansainvälistä politiikkaa saapuu korviimme heti tämän juonnon jälkeen.
Ja juuri on puhuttu Pohjoismaiden yhteisöstä puolustuksesta ja sen tärkeydestä. Mutta kuten laulussakin sanotaan, sen lauluja laulat jonka joukossa seisot. Kiitos.
Ja luuloo että saa tehdä ihan mitä haluaa.
Kansanradion aalloilla niin kuin mokkaperut. Jatkan laulus säpinää ja säpinää. Hyvä meininki antaa palaa ja mielipiteet paukkuu. Mehän ollaan kohta niin kuin Iranin kansa. Lähdetään kanulla vaatimaan muutoksia ellei sitten poliitikot sulje tätä Kansanradiota. Mutta jatketaan saman mallin niin kauan kuin pystytään. Heippa!
No siitä tältä, jos toista taas terve. Tuossa taas huomasin, että Itä Naapurissa on voiton päivä. Sitä se tekee kun ei enää valio toimita voita heille. Eipä mulla tämän kummempie tuli vaan mieleen. Moi moi!
Kaurismäen elokuvan hengessä totean että ei ohjelma lopu. Se vain muuttaa muotoaan. Me siirrymme kotimaan politiikkaan.
Mummu Tampereelta taas akset leikkaa niin kansanedustajat saa komeat palkankorotukset. Sama kaava aina. Hei!
Tuossa mieleen että kun kansanedustajat eivät ole läheskään aina paikalla niin osa aikaihtetaan ne. Maksetaan myös kivaa osa aikainen palkka. Niihin täältä tehdään muillekin.
Työhönsä lähimmäisen rakkaus toimii rauhan työstä. Koti uskonto isänmaa kaikille hyvää kesää. Kaikki kärsii edellisen hallituksen velan ottamisesta muitten maitten elättämiseen. Kiitos! Hei!
Mikähän Kuu Ullus olisi käynyt uli opposition edustajiin kun lähtevät eurosien matkaa ulvomaan. Onneksi hallituksessa on vielä tolo kuviini. Heippa!
No nythän nää meidän päättäjät oikein hurjas rupesi. Ydinaseita pitäs Suomeen muka saada. Ei ei ei. Minä kyllä olen Juuse-Leskisen linjoilla ja tässä tapauksessa jos tänne ryvetään ydinaseita tuomaan niin minä julistan oman tonttini ydinaseettomaksi vyöhykkeeksi. Näin toivotteli Veika Pälköneetä.
Eipä oletti linjanäköistä. Ei! No päivää! Uutisten lukija tässä tiedustellei kun en saanut mitään selvää tuosta hallituksen kehysriihestä että muistiko ne ollenkaan sitä asiaa että kun palkankorotukset tulee että ne leikkaisivat myös niistä omista palkankorotuksistaan hepparallaan.
Rahanpuutteen takia kattoo sitten seuraavana vuonna onko mahdollisuus niitä pitää, mutta ei ainakaan tänä vuonna. Ja ne luovat mitä sinne on valmistettu niille jonossa oleville ruokaavailla oleville ihmisille.
Minä voin sanoa nyt sen, että tässä kiertysjaksossakin on luvassa hyvä paketti sote-teemoja viimeisen vuoden ajalta.
Hallitus puhui potilasturvallisuudesta silloin kun hoitajat olivat lakossa. Mutta nyt kun yöpäivystykset katoavat, kuka oikeasti vaarantaa potilasturvallisuuden? Ja mieti Ivaloa, jos jokainen ajetaan Kela-taksilla Rovaniemelle ja takaisin, mitä siinä muka säästetään? Kyse ei ole pelkästään rahasta vaan arvoista.
Sitten minä sanon, että se on laatila tehtävä. Minusta se tehtävä on mahdoton, vaikka sitten maksuttaisiin sata tonnia, niin se ei hoidu se homma. - Kiitos. - Kerttu, minä olisin kysynyt miksi niin mielenterveys ihmisille saa sanoa mitä tahaa, että ne eivät pääse sitten töihin eikä taho päästä mihinkään. Saako niitä kohdella ihan niin kuin haluaa? Eikö niillä ole samat oikeat oikeat tehtäviä?
toisiin loppui. Minun mielestäni on. Hyvää jatkoa. - En halua nimellä esiintyä, mutta paras säästö olisi tohon, että se sote lakkautettaisiin kokonaan ja vanhaa mallia tietäisiin. Terveyskeskus ja rahat käytettäisiin ihmisten hoitamiseen eikä mihinkään niihin sote-henkilöihin tai niihin palkkoihin, mitä nyt uusi sote tarjoaa. - Kuulkaas kaikki. Jos välillä tuntuu, että elämä sukeltaa, muistakaa riittävän suurilla happipulloilla
Siitäkin selviää. Terveiset täältä Sodankylästä!
Meillä kuulemme Suomessa aika huonosti. Se, että jos valmentaja saa potkun, niin siitä tehdään iso numero. Siitä kaikki saa tietää, mutta se on huono asia. Mutta se on seuraava valmentayksitys asia. Ei se pitää iso numero tehdä. Älä tule, että valmentaja on semmoinen syntipukki. Jos seuraavan mennessä on niin valmenta syntipukki, ei muun muassa se ei tee niin iso numero tehdä. Se on seuraava valmentayksitys asia. Ei se tämmönen numero. Ei se kuulu lehdistys, ei se kuulu heille missään tilanteessa.
No jorma täällä sanoo, että kun he moittiin niitä naisten pieniä urheiluasuja, että kyllähän minä se vanha kukkonen, kyllä minä mielellään katso niitä. Ei mulla muuta näkemiin. Kiitos.
Että se on nyt jatko omissa käsissä, eikö se pitäisi olla omissa jaloissa? Kiitos. Hei.
Yksi kysyi minulta, että montako kertaa sinä olette vetänyt tuon, että sellaista. Terveisin Aria.
Menevät nyt useammat jaksot nyt sitten ohitte. Ei mulla sitten muuta. Sitä mietin vaan, että voisiko joskus tehdä niin, että ne urheilut tulis sieltä areenasta ja Kansanradio siltä paikalta radiosta ainoa sunnuntaisin, jolle se kuuluukin. Kiitos.
Näin kesälläkin joka perjantai kello kaksikymmentäyksi. Jos merkkaat sydämen kuvasta ja tilaat ohjelmasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta, niin saat aina ensimmäinen tiedon kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Hyvä heippa. Siirpa Helsingistä hei. Minulla on ongelma. Minulla on kolme radiota, kaksi televisiota ja niissä missään ei ole sellaista kanavaa kuin Areena. Montakohan megahertsia siihen pitäisi laittaa? Kiitos.
Tässä tosiaan on nähtävillä jonkin verran vanhoja Patakakkonen jaksoja, joissa oiva Jaakko Kolmonen on juontajana ja niitä kuvasti kuvasti kaipaisin kyllä lisää jaksoja ja kausia.
Jos olisi mahdollista tätä kautta tätä toivetta saada eteenpäin, tuntuu että hanakasti laittamani toiveet sieltä Ylen sivuston kautta eivät ole nyt menneet oikein perille, kaikuneet kuuroille korville.
Markuksikasti semmoista mietittiin tässä, että missä saukot pesi talvet? Miksei ole enää eläiradio kello viides tytön tai ei muuta? Elmerin moi. Tässä on Kiivas Elberin katsoja. Tämä ei ole ämpäri. Tämä on uusi perukki. Miltä se sunkaalisoppas maistuu? Hei. Heidän täytyy laittaa nyt tähän Kankaradioon.
Tätä räppiä sinne välii. Ei tätä jaksa kukaan kuunnella, jos ei sitä räppiä saa. Kone musiikkia sinne välii. Eihän tätähän menee ihan asian jorisemiseksi. Kiitos. Hei. Nyt ei ole luvassa mitään jorisemista, vaan eräänsoittajan kysymys ja heti perään vastaus siihen. Niitä ennen kerron vielä Kansanradion puhelinnumeron. Se on 0 8 0 0 1 5 4.
kuusi neljä ja puhelu on soittaajalle maksuton ja muistuksena, että sunnuntaisin kello kaksitoista kolmekymmentä alkaen tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmisvastaaaja kolmen tunnin ajan.
kelan eläkkeellä niin ennen oli tämä kummeli ohjelma sieltä tampereelta toholopista ei ollut oloa ollenkaan ohjelma kummeli oli oli kovaa sanaa ennen kummeli mutta nyt on nämä uutiset niin tuota kummeli ja uutiset ovat tulleet kummelin tilalle amerikan kummeli tämä trumpetti ja sitten tämä myrkkykääpiö putleri ja metkupeflitti ja.
vätyyrohvi siellä vankeudessa ja kätyyrohvi heikossa hapeessa ja viktori orpana näin mutta tuota kummeliahan tämä on lyhyesti sanottuna mutta näin kiitoksia meidän niin sanottu vuosikooste on ansainnut myös runonurkkauksensa sen aika on nyt ei täällä halua se tässä on tämmönen runonpätkä suosittu sellainen on saatu testyä meille kaikille.
huomessa asuillemme kitemme tavalliset tallaajat tykätään kun saa omassa asiansa sinne lykät koko suomi saa heti sen tieteen tärkeimmät eteenpäin tieteen kansanradiossa kaikkea saa kuulla ei tarvita turhaa luulla meitä myös paljon helpottaa kun saa mielipiteensä ilmoittaa vuosittu ohjelma sen takia ettei ole sääntöjä.
ja siinä erinomaiset tekijät kansa lasse ja lauri siinä ne erinomaiset tekijät niille kiitoksia ja hyvää yhty jatkoa kaikille kiitos hei hei.
sitten teen minä tuonne sen sitten joskus ja kun sitten toimeen tartutaan tee jo heti tänään tai huomenna älä mieti joskus ja kun se voi halveksi jäädä kokonaan eikä unelmas halveesti toteudukaan.
ja ristikkolehti kerron sinulle hauskoja juttuja kysyn ootko nähnyt tuttuja ja on hämme nimittäin sut nyt sen kaikkein tutuimman.
kiitos kansanradiolle se on hirveen mukavaa ja hauskaa kun pienillä aasinsilloilla hypähdetään asiasta toiseen ja välikommentit on mukavia se vähän piristää vaikka surullisia asioita ja olipa hauska pieni runoilukin siellä lopussa sunnuntaina noin runot on hauskoja ja suomalaista aika hyvin tekemää runoja. hei. tämä meidän kierrätysjaksomme on jo aivan loppusuoralla.
vielä kuullaan ainakin nuoriin ja naapureihin liittyviä ajatuksia ennen viimeisiä puheluita minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää koiviston lauri kiittää ja kumartaa kansanradio jälleen viikon päästä.
ei käy missään ainakaan tämmöisissä pikkupaikoissa kun ähtä. no ei mulla muuta. morjens. päivää täällä kertuu mahrestan ratsastusta ja tänään meillä oli sellaista asiaa että aivan että veikkolan nuorisotila on auki vaan kaksi kertaa viikossa ja vaan kolme kertaa viikossa kun on pari tämän viikon. tämä on hyvin vakava asia ja meidän veikkolaisille nuorille tämä on tärkeää just kiitos.
tämmöinen että hallitus rupeaa rajoittaa nuorten nettikäyttöä. se on vähän niin kuin kieltolakiaikanaan joka lisäisi vaan sitä. se on minun mielestäni te. kiitos.
hyvät kuuntelijat ottakaa oppia konsta pylkkäsen sanoista maailmankaikkeudessa ihmisellä on kusiaisen verran valtaa. hyvää jatkoa kiitos.
Ei, te uuteliaat näe naapurit. Kun olette niin uuteliaita naapurestanne, kuka menee ja tulee, niin voisitteko välillä katsoa, mites teidän naapurin oven takanaat. Elääkö se ihminen vanhus vai ei. Et voi virua siellä monta päivää, mutta silloin kun tarvis vaatii, niin ei tule apua. Hävytöntä!
No naapurin pelkoinen on se kyllä Kälämiukko, kun se vaan syö ja haisee!
Naalittansa! Nyt kantan radilla! Hyvä oppilma, kiitos, nai!
Nyt mä sen keksin. Minäpä lähdenkin tuonne maailman napaan. Mä kuulin radiossa just, että siinä menee kaikki eläkeläisesti, jolloin eläkeläisesti on hyvä olla. Ja kun mulla on tästä ympäristössä niin paljon omaa napaan tuijotta, niin maailmaa jo vähän pikkuhiljaa kyllästyy. Hei hei!